all right and we got a big night tonight
welcome to Hannity and coming up a new
low for America's historically
um popular vice president uh Kamala
Harris she has now set an all-time
record low congratulations also the Bud
Light Executives you know the ones
responsible for the company's woke
partnership with trans influencer Dylan
Mulvaney they are no longer with the
company according to the Daily Caller we
have full details Straight Ahead also
tonight Democrats are trying to ban the
one and only one good thing that New
York City has great pizza all in the
name of climate change the only one
thing that is halfway decent about this
Adam Schiff Hall they can't do this to
me and later one professor of Penn State
he is accusing his own University of
labeling English language instruction as
white supremacy he'll join us all right
but first the walls are closing in on
Merrick Garland's uh politicized and
weaponized doj and the top Biden family
Syndicate protector yep it's happening
we know that somebody is lying and
according to the New York Post David
Weiss he was the U.S attorney that was
tasked with investigating Hunter Biden
told not one but six witnesses that his
hands his hands were completely and
totally tied in regard to this
investigation into Hunter and to Joe IRS
whistleblower uh Gary shapely claims
that wife said quote I'm not deciding of
uh the deciding official on whether
charges are filed that whistleblower
Gary shapely now is speaking out look at
this from CBS
there were personal expenses that were
taken as business expenses prostitutes
sex club memberships hotel rooms for
purported drug dealers how much did
Hunter Biden Owen taxes so from 2014 to
2019 it was 2.2 million dollars I
documented exactly what happened and it
doesn't seem to match what the attorney
general or the U.S attorney are saying
today there were certain investigative
steps that we weren't allowed to take
that could have led us to President
Biden and you wanted to take him
we needed to take them and you weren't
allowed to take that's correct by the
way no to Hunter Biden uh Hunter uh sex
club uh initiation fees they are not tax
deductible even clubs you get thrown out
of because you're a jackass which
happened anyway Hunter's not going to
spend a year in jail now Weiss allegedly
now claiming that Biden appointed a U.S
attorney from D.C would not allow him to
charge hunter in his district he wanted
to Weiss also allegedly says he was
blocked from bringing charges in
California by another Biden appointed
U.S attorney ultimately this refusal to
prosecute meant that Hunter's tax crimes
that are alleged from 2014 and 15 Etc uh
stemming from his work with barisma
Holdings the oil giant Ukraine would be
excluded that also meant that the
statute of limitation they were allowed
to expire enabling the doj to sanitize
Hunter's charges and according to the
IRS was whistleblower and it's not just
one but the one you heard from Weiss
quote asks for a special counsel
Authority from the doj America Garland
but he was denied that Authority he said
he had more power than a special counsel
here's where things get very very dicey
for all involved you see attorney
general mayor Garland is telling a much
different story and he told the story
repeatedly take a look
Mr Weiss Who was appointed by President
Trump as the U.S attorney in Delaware
and assigned this matter during the
previous administration would be
permitted to continue his investigation
and to make a decision to prosecute
any way in which he wanted to and in any
District in which he wanted to Mr Weiss
reportedly wanted to have the powers
you've convert on special counsels was
that request ever made and if so uh did
you why did you reject it it was not the
only person with authority to
make somebody a special counsel or
refuse to make somebody a special
counsel as the Attorney General Mr Weiss
never made that request to me can you
explain the rationale for not appointing
special counsel in this case sir Weiss
had in fact more Authority than a
special counsel would had he has
complete as he had and has complete
Authority as I said to bring a case
anywhere he wants
in his discretion does Delaware U.S
attorney lack independent charging
authority over certain criminal
allegations against the president's son
outside of the District of Delaware
he would have to bring if it's in
another District he would have to bring
the case in another District but as I
said I have promised to ensure that he's
able to carry out his investigation and
that he be able to run it and if he uh
needs to bring it in another
jurisdiction he will have full authority
to do that he was denied that full
Authority not once but twice and as you
can see Garland continued to Echo those
exact same claims over and over again
also he included those claims in a
testimony made before Congress sworn
testimony so was Merrick Garland lying
under oath in other words did he commit
perjury to protect the Biden family
Syndicate has the weaponization of Joe
Biden's Department of Justice now
finally caught up with all of them
because now tonight we have six separate
IRS Witnesses whistleblowers that have
documented Weiss's prosecutorial woes in
real time they also took contemporaneous
notes in real time uh and uh by the way
they're not all lying they were writing
down what Weiss was saying yeah this guy
won't let me prosecute here I can't go
to California there the exact opposite
of what Merrick Garland was testifying
to under oath now think about it
Garland's doj just gifted did Hunter
Biden with one of the most generous
sweetheart deals in history you don't
believe me ask Wesley Snipe ask others
that have been charged with with crimes
that Hunter had been charged with but
got three four years in jail this is a
deal that kept Hunter out of jail
protected the big guy Joe Biden from
facing any legal scrutiny and according
to wise and what he told six
whistleblowers again they took notes in
order to achieve these tremendous
results the doj interfered in this
election they ignored nonpartisan
investigators they blocked charges in
two different states and they let the
statute of limitations pass and then
they lied about it under oath uh didn't
John Durham just point out of the FBI
and the doj gave special treatment to
Hillary Clinton compared to Donald Trump
the system in this country is corrupt
Joe Biden's doj and A.G is corrupt they
have politicized the doj they have
weaponized the doj and they have
politicized and they have weaponized the
FBI hierarchy and right now there is a
mountain of evidence that Joe Biden
played a crucial and critical role in
Hunter Biden's Farm business deals yeah
he actually lied to us repeatedly during
the campaign in 2020 for example in July
of 2017 Hunter berated a Chinese
National from that state Energy company
for quote not fulfilling a commitment uh
quote I'm sitting here with my father
and would like to understand why the
commitment made has not been fulfilled
Hunter continued quote I will make
certain that the man sitting next to me
pops and every person he knows and my
ability to hold the grudge that you will
regret not following my direction he
thinks he's Vito Corleone here I am
sitting here waiting for the call with
my father then lo and behold on August
3rd more demands from Hunter her to
another associate from this Chinese
Energy company quote if you think this
is about money it's not the bidens they
are the best I know at doing exactly
what the chairman wants from this
partnership let's not quibble over
peanuts uh Biden's doing what the
chairman wants uh the chairman of a
communist Chinese Energy company
that doesn't exactly sound too good now
does it and Joey's sitting right next to
him and get this according to reports
the very next day a hundred thousand
dollars magically was wired to a hunter
related account then another five
million dollars was wired on August the
8th a few days later so what were the
bidens doing for this money besides
trying to shake them down in their best
Vito Corleone Godfather act that they
possibly could put together what did the
chairman exactly expect for all of this
and uh just who is the chairman there
are questions that need to be answered
but they thanks to Merrick Garland's doj
neither Hunter nor Joe Biden will be
forced to explain these suspicious
activities quote mission accomplished
right Merrick Garland it is imperative
that Hunters slap on the wrist plea deal
this must be stopped by this judge in
this case immediately the people in this
country need to find the truth we need
to know if Weiss did in fact tell the
truth to these six IRS whistleblowers
that took contemporaneous notes real
time it is imperative that if in fact
all that happened that mayor Garland
then be impeached by the Republicans in
the house now of course since Biden
pretends to be such an honorable man who
knew nothing about hunter's foreign
business dealings he could voluntarily
answer questions about his involvement
in these Shady deals he can explain why
a period in pictures with Hunter's Farm
business partners and why he met with
all these foreign Nationals inside and
outside the White House and why he lied
repeatedly and lies to this day about
all of it but Joe Biden will never do
that he's not honest he's not a decent
person he won't even acknowledge his
four-year-old granddaughter the White
House won't even list Hunter on their
official visitor logs by the way even
Obama did that and sadly the abusively
corrupt bias media in this country the
mob they'll never hold Biden accountable
this show will and circle back Jen saki
who was once Biden's Chief propaganda at
the White House now she's got a good
paying gig over at another propagandist
outlet and conspiracy Network msdnc and
she wants you to know that Hunter's
sweetheart deal from his daddy's doj and
the subsequent celebration at the White
House State dinner is little more than a
feel-good story about a father's deep
Abiding Love for his precious little son
who's pictured in lots of compromising
compromising positions take a look
what we saw with Hunter appearing at the
state dinner was in my suspicion was the
president his son wanted to come so his
son's going to come to the dinner was
that optically easier for the White
House and the White House communications
team absolutely not but I suspect that
was more in the family circumstance of
him wanting to come and wanting to just
the president wanting to show that he
loves his son and he's standing by him
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else